Speaker 1: So we laid out we had the first
January six commission months ago, proposed
and rejected by Republicans.
We then got close to another one.
But then when Nancy Pelosi said Jim Jordan
and Jim Banks, they can't be on the commission,
they're part of the problem.
Republicans went nuts.
Now they're saying they're going to do their
own commission.
And it's an absolute and complete joke.
The reaction from Republicans and the right
wing media to this has been to start pushing
new conspiracy theories about what happened
on January 6th.
Laura Ingram running on Fox News, a headline
called Nancy The Insurrectionist.
Pelosi exploits January 6th in a ruthless
power grab because she said two of the five
Republican choices can't be on the commission.
Remember that Republicans could have gone
forward with the commission has proposed months
ago and Nancy Pelosi wouldn't even have had
the power to reject any of the choices of
the Republicans.
Then the right wing media continuing.
Tucker Carlson actually inviting Jim Jordan
onto his program last night.
Jim Jordan is one of the members of Congress
that Nancy Pelosi said, no, this guy is an
insider.
He can't be on the commission and pushed the
conspiracy theories, still baseless, that
the riots were a setup by the FBI.
Speaker 2: Christopher Wray refused to get
on a conference call about preparation for
January six before it happened.
They knew it was coming.
They didn't protect the building.
They let the protesters in.
The FBI has a long history of setting up crimes.
Speaker 1: And just now, remember, every single
one of these things has to be looked at in
detail.
There was the videos of law enforcement moving
aside.
It's a typical crowd control thing where when
the crowd is overwhelming the crowd control
measures and the crowd controllers and law
enforcement, to a certain degree, it's typical
that those doing the crowd control will move
aside and sort of like allow the perimeter
to be shifted because it starts to present
a danger to them as well as to the people,
to the public, that it's it's not it's not
the big smoking gun that these Republicans
want to make it out to be.
The big smoking gun.
Is Trump refusing to actually allow the National
Guard in for hours, despite being asked
Speaker 2: that it in Michigan?
We're going to get to do it in a second.
Why isn't there a good faith investigation
into the FBI's behavior or do Republicans
somehow trust the FBI?
Well, we're talking you may remember a few
weeks ago when we had the FBI director in
front of the Judiciary Committee, I asked
him about what happened to the Hoopers up
in the state of Alaska who were there?
A door was kicked in.
They were handcuffed that held at gunpoint
and interrogated for four hours.
They weren't even in the capital.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's the that's the idea
that the FBI this is the reaction to the commission.
The FBI set it up.
Then Laura Ingraham does a segment with Kevin
McCarthy where McCarthy starts floating this
idea that it was Nancy Pelosi that was responsible
for the National Guard not being there
Speaker 2: when the riots were going on in
the National Guard were there and Nancy Pelosi
was criticizing because they they were at
the Lincoln Memorial protecting it.
Was there a decision made by the speaker not
to have the National Guard at the Capitol
that day when they found me?
Speaker 1: That's the new one.
It's not Trump.
That was Pense McCarthy.
Everybody saying send in the troops and Trump
saying no as he watches this from the White
House.
Now they're saying it's all Pelosi's fault.
That's what it is.
And Jim Banks, another one of the insiders
floating the exact same idea or did.
Speaker 2: And I would ask the tough questions
that they didn't want to answer about the
systemic breakdown of security at the Capitol
on January six.
And ultimately, who's responsible for that?
The speaker of the House.
They don't want to go there.
They knew we were going to ask the tough questions.
Speaker 1: So that's the concerted effort.
Now, you can just see they've decided this
is going to be what we're going to talk about.
Let's say it's and it was Nancy Pelosi responsible
for what happened.
And then lastly, here is Tucker Carlson attacking
Harry Dunne, the black police officer.
Sir, who was attacked by rioters on January
six.
I mean, it's beyond the pale information.
Speaker 2: What's the answer?
And of course, she doesn't have one.
Speaking of disingenuous, so the committee
will proceed with one party, what will look
like we'll think MSNBC with subpoena power.
On Tuesday, Pelosi will call a Capitol police
officer called Harry Dun Dun will pretend
to speak for the country's law enforcement
community.
But it turns out Don has very little in common
with your average cop.
Don is an angry left wing political activist
whose social media feeds are full of praise,
not coincidentally, for Nancy Pelosi.
Here's a picture of the two of them together.
Racism is so American, Harry Dunne wrote a
one post that when you protested, people think
you were protesting America hashtag leave
it to whites to tell blacks what is racist.
Hashtag I stand with you on Ohmar hashtag
squad.
Harry Dunne, ladies and gentlemen, just other
facts,
Speaker 1: so the support the police people
now attacking the police victimized by the
Trump rioters on January 6th, these people
cannot be trusted to investigate, obviously,
but they can't even be relied upon to provide
even the most fundamental, unquestionable
facts.
So we'll see what this starts to look like
next week.
Will say much more probably on Monday.
Remember that Monday, August 16th, is the
16th anniversary of The David Pakman Show
will be doing a one day membership special.
I'd love for you to participate, get notified
on the 16th simply by getting on my newsletter
at David Pakman Dotcom.
Remember to grab a membership and get instant
access to the bonus show at Join Pakman dot
com, we do an extra show every day on today's
bonus show.
We'll talk about the Ben and Jerry's situation,
big ice cream drama that many
people have asked me to comment on.
Join Pakman Dotcom sign up today